- Hey guys, Dr. Berg here.
In this video, we're gonna share with you
the power of intermittent fasting, okay?
Now, intermittent fasting is a tool.
It's not a diet. It doesn't
tell you what to eat.
It's a pattern of eating. Okay?
It's a pattern of eating and not eating.
It's not about cutting calories.
It's just changing when you
eat and when you don't eat.
Okay. So that's what
we're gonna talk about.
So why would you want to do this anyway?
Because it is one, if not
the most important factors
in weight loss, okay?
Let's talk about why.
Because it triggers two
main hormones in your body.
The most powerful ones,
one is growth hormone,
which is anti-aging and the
most powerful fat-burning hormone.
There are six fat-burning hormones.
Growth hormone is the most
powerful fat-burning hormone
to protect your muscles,
to build lean body mass,
and also just to lose actual fat, okay?
And then you have insulin.
Insulin is also a very powerful
hormone in that it actually
will help you store fat if
you want to gain weight,
which you don't want to do
that, you want to lose weight.
But here's the thing, in
the presence of insulin,
you cannot lose weight.
It's such a dominating hormone,
it will block growth hormone.
So it's the hormone that makes you fat.
It's the hormone that gives you the gut.
If you see someone with a fat gut,
they have too much insulin.
So these are the two powerful hormones
that you're gonna influence.
Now, let's look at what's happening.
This tool or technique can
really heal insulin resistance,
where you have the pancreas
pumping out way more insulin
than you need, five to seven times,
because what happens when
you have too much insulin,
the cells start blocking it
and then your body doesn't get
to return communication.
So it's like talking to your
child and they have ear plugs.
You're gonna increase your
volume because the person
is ignoring you.
There's no two-way communication.
So if the pancreas
doesn't get the feedback
that the insulin is connecting,
it sends more insulin through the channel.
So you have a situation where you
have resistance of
insulin, it's not working,
low insulin in the cell, low glucose,
but then you have high amounts
of insulin in other places,
which is very destructive
because it's pre-diabetes,
creates a lot of problems, okay?
So what we want to do is we
want to start where you're at,
and then graduate this way over time.
It's kind of like there's different levels
of intermittent fasting from
not intermittent fasting
to some serious fat burning over here.
So let's say you start
with five meals a day
or six meals a day.
You have breakfast, lunch, snacks.
Some people do breakfast, snack, lunch,
snack, dinner, snack, right?
That's a lot of people that do that.
The principle of intermittent
fasting hormonally is that
every time you eat you spike insulin.
See, people have thought that only when
you eat carbohydrates, you spike insulin.
No, no, no.
Eating in general will
increase insulin regardless
of what you eat.
Even a snack, even if it's healthy.
So we have a situation where
this person's spiking insulin
all day long.
Our bodies are not designed
to eat and graze all day long.
So we want to switch to three meals a day
with no snacks, okay?
So that's the first step,
three meals a day, no snacking.
The ability to go from
one meal to the next,
without being hungry,
involves eating more fat.
So you have to add more fat to that meal.
I'm gonna put some
links down, what to eat.
But this video is not about what to eat.
It's about the pattern.
So you get three meals here,
and then if you want to take
it to the next level and burn
even more fat, you want to
do a pattern of 16 to eight,
16 hours of fasting and
eight hour window of eating.
So let's say you get up in the morning
and you're not hungry.
Well, don't eat. Wait until you're hungry.
The ideal situation is to go
four hours when you wake up,
at least four hours before
you eat the first meal.
So let's say, you eat at
10 o'clock in the morning.
And you got up at six.
So that means that your
last meal is going to be
at six o'clock at night, so
we have an eight hour window.
Where this, you might
get up and eat at eight
and you might eat at eight at night.
So you really haven't
given enough fasting.
A little bit in between, but not.
The real power of intermittent
fasting is through
the night and in the morning.
And actually at nighttime
when you're sleeping,
and then in the morning,
that's when you really
have the uninterrupted
serious fat burning.
Not necessarily as much between the meals,
but it is a factor.
So that's why we want 16
hours of fasting with this.
So we try to keep that window when you
have your three meals, okay?
Does that make sense?
Now, if we want to take it even further
and really turn on the fat burning,
we want to go to two
meals, but we want a window
of 20 hours of fasting.
Do you know what that
would do to your waistline,
your stomach?
So we go for 20 hours of fasting and
only four hour window of eating.
So we want to get up and wait
until let's say 12 o'clock
or one, have the first meal and then have
the next meal four hours later.
So let's say you eat at
one and then your next meal
is at five.
So you have four hours
there where you basically,
you ate, but then you have 20
hours of serious fat burning.
If we then add intermittent
exercise to that,
high intensity interval
training, then it's over.
That would be icing on the cake.
Well, maybe I shouldn't
say icing on the cake.
That's gonna be the meat and potatoes.
No, don't listen to me.
But the point is that
it's gonna take some time
to transition over to these
different levels, okay?
Don't think it happens in a minute.
If you've destroyed your
metabolism through dieting
or the HCG diet, which is 500 calories
or some other stress event,
then what's gonna happen,
it's gonna take some time to
gradually kind of move over
to the next one, but
you'll get comfortable.
We don't want you to be
headachy and have a lot
of side effects between the meals.
And this transition from here
to here could take, you know,
three weeks, but this one
could take a month or two,
or even three months before
you get to this point,
could take even longer.
But then you're really burning fat. Okay?
So I just wanted to
cover the power of this,
what it is, and how you
would do it starting here
and gradually over here, all right?
Put your comments below.
Thanks for watching.
I just wanted to take a
moment out to thank you
for your amazing feedback
that you guys are giving me.
It's just mind blowing
the successes, the wins.
I created a link down below,
so you can actually type
out your full success story.
And if you have a before
and after with weight loss,
that would be awesome.
And if you don't have
a success with weight,
but other things, just
put an image of yourself
and your personal success story.
And I would love to read it
and also share it with others.
So I want to just thank you
in advance for doing that,
but there's a link down below.
Fill it out. I can't wait to read it.